public hearings begin and we review the
supposedly bombshell testimony of the
Democratic witnesses I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why have you not gotten a VPN
yet visit expressvpn dot-com /ban okay
we've got a ton to get to today i'll
tell you a little bit later on in the
show about how things went at boston
university last night it was pretty
interesting and I think a lot of fun but
of course we begin with the news of the
day which is all the fallout from
yesterday's bombshell testimony so much
bombshell okay so here is the way that
the New York Times is covering this
thing their headline says behind the
star witness Democrats take their
impeachment case to the public ooh a
star witness they say their goal is to
transform what might seem like an
abstract debate over foreign policy into
high crimes and misdemeanors in the
public mind as Republicans argue there
is no case for impeachment Peter Baker
is the writer he says William Taylor was
the witness the Democrats had hoped
Robert Muller would be but was not the
image at least of a wise fatherly figure
with Kevlar credibility expressing
restrained but unmistakable disapproval
of what he found when he turned over the
rock his objective media coverage writer
so much journalism a House Democrats led
off their highly anticipated impeachment
hearings on Wednesday with a figure
projecting probity a combat veteran
turned career diplomat who narrated with
a deep baritone voice reminiscent of
Walter Cronkite's what he saw is the
corruption of American foreign policy to
advance president Trump's personal
political interests it was not clear
that minds were changed shouldn't you
lead with that rightly said that the
question is whether any minds were
changed or whether the testimony itself
changed anything or offer to anything
that was bombshell anew as opposed to he
appeared to be a gray fox this William
Taylor fellow patriotic stolid man this
was a hero of the Republic and because
we've heard the hero of the Republic
routine before from the median didn't
change anything hey James Comey hero of
the Republic Andrew McCabe hero of the
Republic vind Minh hero of the
Republican now it's William Taylor hero
of the Republic now listen you look at
his public service the guy is in fact a
hero of the Republic for his public
service but that does not mean that he
testified as to anything impeachable
yesterday and yet the media are making
this out to be really about the optics
and that in the end really is sort of it
betrays the agenda the agenda here is
that this is all about the optics and
not about anything new nothing new has
actually happened here that's the dirty
little secret because we can go through
the testimony yesterday and nothing new
no new ground was broken instead it was
all the same ground that we've heard
before sort of trod over repeatedly and
so in terms of substance I don't think
the American people are gonna hear
anything new that changes their mind but
in terms of optics the Democrats are
hoping that if they bring out a bunch of
gravelly voiced very somber speakers who
have long histories in American foreign
policy then this will somehow turn the
American public against Trump well if
people cared about that Trump wouldn't
be President let's face this thing okay
Donald Trump was not elected because
people had a ton of respect for
America's institutions he was he was
elected specifically because people did
not have a ton of respect in America's
institutions and putting out somebody
with Walter Cronkite's voice isn't gonna
change any of that
just on a purely political level okay
but the New York Times says it was not
clear that minds were changed certainly
they were not inside the room and most
likely not elsewhere on Capitol Hill
while Republicans and Democrats were
locked into their positions long ago nor
were there any immediate signs that the
hearing penetrated the general public
well major television networks broke
into regular programming to carry alive
there was little sense of a riveted
country putting everything aside to
watch Eila Watergate okay someone are we
talking about I love this line this is
my favorite line from the New York Times
it's just spectacular but whether or not
voters were watching history certainly
was what the f is that supposed to mean
history was watching what is it like
seriously what does that mean history
was watching history is watching
everything his reason watching you on
the toilet
if by history is watching you mean that
history is something that happens and
then people later read about it that
could be anything right it could be any
history was well I mean if history was
watching that changes everything New
York Times you've changed everything
near it's amazing over the course of
five hours of relatively sober testimony
interrupted by fewer partisan
histrionics than might have been
expected mr. Taylor the top American
diplomat in Ukraine and George Kent a
Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
according to the New York Times laid out
what they saw of the president's efforts
to pressure a foreign power to provide
damaging information about his
Democratic rivals mr. Taylor was the
star witness
Democrats have sought for a long time as
opposed to Muller who sort of bumbled
and fumbled and looked old like mr.
Muller mr. Taylor 72 is a septuagenarian
Vietnam veteran with a chiseled face and
reassuring gray hair I didn't realize
that that gray hair was reassuring
tell my wife about that as I as I age
here my hair is reassuring that's some
solid writing right there
reassuring gray when was the last time
you're like I you know I'm I'm feeling a
little bit nervous oh thank god a man
with gray hair
ah I'm so reassured now a chiseled face
and reassuring gray hair after a
lifetime of service to his country but
where Mr Muller seems unsteady and
uncertain last summer when he testified
about his special council investigation
into Russian interference
mr. Taylor came across as calm confident
and in command
well literation calm confident cool
collected in command of the facts as he
knew them with a more in sadness than
anger tone he told lawmakers that in
decades of public service under
administration's of both parties he had
never seen any president warp foreign
policy for his own personal advantage
the way mr. Trump tried to do but mr.
Taylor was careful to retain an official
neutrality on what Congress should do
with his testimony and when lawmakers
tried to goad him into taking a more
political stance
he smiled serenely and declined to take
the bait okay so that this was the tape
from the New York Times and the take
from the Washington Post was quite
similar the take from the Washington
Post says new testimony ties Trump more
directly to Ukraine pressure campaign
Elise V Beck reporting after weeks in
which President Fromm's top aides have
figured as the major players in the
Ukraine narrative testimony in the first
few hours of the public impeachment
hearings Wednesday thrust Trump himself
back to center stage acting ambassador
to Ukraine William Taylor told lawmakers
about a previously unknown effort by the
President to make sure Ukraine was
looking into his political opponents a
phone conversation he said from had with
the top US diplomat asking about the
status of the investigations the phone
conversations described by Taylor gave
Democrats a chance to renew questions
about Trump's personal involvement in
the effort to push Ukraine to
investigate his political opponents
while the United States withheld
security assistance and a sought-after
White House meeting we'll hear about
exactly what Taylor had to say on this
in just one second okay but the the
media are trying to claim basically that
the testimony even though it didn't
change things it probably should change
things even though it made things it
didn't make things any different even
though there wasn't anything new there
was something brand-new we'll get to
that in just one second the truth or
falsity of those statements cuz here's
the reality on an I'm trying to be as
objective as I can and you'll know if I
say that the hearing is bad for Trump
I'll say that hearing is bad for Trump
and if I think that a phone call
bad for Trump I'll say it's bad for
Trump I at least try to analyze these
things as objectively as I can even
though I think that the Democrats have
not proven their case I don't think that
yesterday was particularly bad for Trump
I really don't think it hurt him in any
serious way the me they're trying to
spend it that way I do not think that
that is accurate that's why they're
they're sort of falling back on the line
of the New York Times history was
watching yeah well history can watch all
at once but it hadn't happened yet so
you know come back to me in 20 years and
we'll talk about how history watch I
don't even know who's gonna win the next
election go get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the watch
upon your wrist okay so I have this
brand new watch Guinness thing this is
beautiful is it watch from a vintage
hero VIN cherrylle check this thing out
it is spectacular
right it's a really nice watch and it
will not cost you a fortune this one is
called the rogue it is a chronograph I'm
kind of a watch guy I really do like
watches on acai and watches I like
fashion watches this is a really solid
durable beautiful watch really is well
crafted head over to vin cheryl watches
comm forward slash shapiro to see my
favorite picks and don't forget to use
coach shapiro at checkout for 15% off
your entire order
I like Ventura watches so much by the
way I just got one for my sister for her
birthday I gave one of my dad you can
engrave their watches which is actually
a pretty cool feature in fact french
arrow sent me one that says wait for it
facts don't care about your feelings on
the back of the watch which is an
awesome feature when you're getting a
gift for somebody for the holidays or
for a birthday and we're coming up on
the Christmas season so it's a great
time to get somebody of inch arrow watch
from their small batch manufacturing
process to their customer service then
Cheryl does everything in-house nothing
is actually outsourced then Cheryl
believes that watches make a statement
about you and they do write a nice watch
is something that catches the eye it
starts conversations plus you feel good
every time you look down and you see
what time it is people notice a watch if
you wear one so why not wear something
nice you really should check out VIN
Charo today the deal is too good to pass
up
go to vin Cheryl watches comets VI n CER
o watches comm /up arrow and use code
Shapiro to get 15% off that is VI NC er
o watches comm /p row use code Shapiro
to get 15% off they've a wide variety of
styles right got these this is a little
bit more sporty the rogue that I'm
wearing they've got other types of watch
that are a little bit less sporty but
but great for dinner they even have some
automatic watches which is really cool
they're not a watch person an automatic
watch is one that's not run off battery
power it actually just charges off
the movement of your of your wrist
they've got all sorts of varieties all
sorts of colors they've got four men
they've got four women it really is
fantastic go check them out right now at
Vinci wrote watches calm /ur Pierrot
used code Shapiro to get 15% off okay so
the Democrats thought they were gonna
have a big day yesterday and it turned
out not to be a big day for them
yesterday it started off with Adam
Schiff at the very opening saying this
this process was meant to be a
punishment for criminal activity not a
punishment for political activity but a
lot of the testimony was based around
the opposite idea that a bunch of people
who are in the foreign policy
establishment didn't like Trump's
foreign policy and they were angry at
Trump's foreign policy and that's the
real reason why they were going after
Trump right the real reason they're
going after Trump is because they
disagreed with him withholding aid from
Ukraine and they couldn't see why he was
doing it and so they were mad about that
now does that mean that Trump was doing
something that was corrupt or doesn't
mean they just disagreed with him about
the foreign policy here is a Adam Schiff
at the opening suggesting that
impeachment was originally meant to be a
punishment for criminal activity which
sort of cuts again he hasn't proved any
criminal activity here our answer to
these questions will affect not only the
future of this presidency but the future
of the presidency itself and what kind
of conduct or misconduct the American
people may come to expect from their
commander-in-chief there are a few
actions as consequential as the
impeachment of a president while the
founders did not intend that impeachment
be employed for mere differences over
policy
they also made impeachment a
constitutional process that the Congress
must utilize as necessary okay so again
he's saying this is not a political
thing it's a criminal thing and yet they
have yet to bring forth the elements
necessary to prove any sort of criminal
abuse of power Shiv the chief is doing
this routine where he pretends that he's
reserving judgment so yesterday he
simultaneously said that he's reserving
judgment and also that Trump's abuse of
power is terrible which means he's not
reserving judgment obviously here's Adam
Schiff suggesting that he is reserving
judgment in all of this that's right
he's opening an impeachment inquiry
where he's reserving like really if you
believe this I've got a bridge in
Brooklyn it's available for just a
couple of dollars and I can make this
magic happen
just for you right now here's Adam
Schiff talking about reserving judgment
I'm reserving judgment on
the ultimate questions once the
testimony is complete about what should
fall from this what are the consequences
it is certainly the case that
the founders were deeply concerned that
a president United States one day may be
elected to office that would put his or
her interests above the country that
would sacrifice our national security
either to get a political a personal
favor or owing to some foreign influence
oh he's holding off on judgment that's
how that's the sound of a man holding
off on judgment flanked by a bunch of
other people holding off on judgment
Emily Democrats we're going to vote for
impeachment okay so listen Adams this
thing's already been preset we already
know that that's why when Devin Nunes
who is the Republican chair of the House
Intelligence Committee is the the
Republican leader on the in the House
Intelligence Committee when he says that
this is just a low-rent sequel to the
Russia hoax that has some credibility
given the fact that it does feel like a
partisan hit by Democrats now that
doesn't mean that there aren't questions
to be asked about Trump's behavior I've
said this all along but does this feel
like a partisan exercise you bet your
ass it feels like a partisan exercise
here's Devin Nunes pointing this out
ambassador Taylor and mr. Kent I like to
welcome you here I'd like to
congratulate you for passing the
Democrat star chamber auditions held for
the last weeks in the basement of the
Capitol
it seems you agreed witting or unwitting
ly to participate in a drama but the
main performance the Russia hoax has
ended and you've been cast in the
low-rent Ukranian sequel okay so yeah
and that's an overstatement because
again we don't know exactly what all the
evidence is but there is a widespread
perception in the United States and I
think that it's well based perception
that this is more of a partisan effort
than it is really an effort to curb the
misuse of the power of the presidency
okay so then we get to the actual
testimony and here is the problem for
the Democrats the actual testimony
didn't really change anything it didn't
really change anything so the only real
bombshell yesterday is that Bill Taylor
suggested that he heard somebody from
his staff tell him about a conversation
that he overheard with President Trump
in which Trump was talking about
investigations and he didn't hear Trump
side of the conversation apparently he
only heard the person on the other side
of the conversation that is Bill
Taylor's accounts of this magical
magical conversation so Taylor had
suggested that there was a previously
unknown effort by the press
make sure Ukraine was looking into his
political opponents a phone conversation
he said Trump had with the top US
diplomat asking about the status of the
investigations but the diplomat was not
Bill Taylor and hearing that lies the
problem
I built Taylor their star witness a man
with reassuring gray hair I mean that
hair so reassuring
yesterday he says listen I can't tell
you what was in Trump's head I can tell
you what I heard from people that hell
does that like really you can tell us
what you heard from people this would
not make for good evidence in any
criminal trial I can tell you what I
heard from people I can tell you what I
heard from people you can tell me what
you heard from people we can all talk
about what we heard from people and then
we can all be reporters for TMZ like
what what does this mean here's Bill
Taylor I can tell you what I heard from
people very important stuff what you
heard from people what what I can do
here for you today is tell you what I
heard from people and in this case it
was what I heard from ambassador Solomon
he described conditions for the Security
Assistance and the White House meeting
in in those terms that is that were
dependent upon conditioned on pursuing
these investigations and you heard that
from ambassador sunland himself correct
correct
okay so he can tell you what he heard
from people which is very exciting what
he heard from people now does that
matter it matters when they bring
sunland dead right because now they're
going to say well either Taylor is lying
or sunland is lying or somebody's making
mistakes somewhere in here so matters
for sunland but does that go to trumps
state of mind not particularly because
again Taylor has never had a
conversation with Trump and yet you had
Taylor drawing these fantastical
conclusions about Trump I mean these
these very strong conclusions about his
perception of what Trump was doing
listen he can speculate as much as he
wants and he can draw any conclusion he
wants it's a free country and I'm not
saying that his conclusion is
implausible all I'm saying is that his
conclusion is based purely on
conversations that he had with people
who were not Donald Trump I'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the status of your home right
now is it is it everything good at home
you just did the floor it's nice the
walls are nice and then you look around
something looks a little dingy yes the
window coverings you haven't thought
about them have you have you well you
should be thinking about them now since
I've mentioned it go check out blinds
with 50 million windows covered over
30,000 five-star customer reviews blinds
comm is America's number-one online
retailer for affordable quality custom
window coverings blinds.com makes the
whole experience fast and easy plus
every single order gets free samples
free shipping a free online design
consultation you just send them pictures
of your hub of your home and they'll
send back custom recommendations from a
professional for what will work with
your color scheme furniture and specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to ensure that everything looks as good
in person as it does online and that
every order gets free shipping here's
the best part if you accidentally miss
measure where you pick the wrong color
if you screw up
blinds comm will remake your blinds for
free they've been really easy for you go
check them out right now for limited
time my listeners get 20 bucks off at
blinds comm when you use promo code to
bed that is blinds.com promo code Ben
for 20 bucks off faux wood blinds hell
interest rates roller shades and more
blinds kaam promo code Ben rules and
restrictions do indeed apply ok so here
is Bill Taylor drawing a very strong
conclusion from the fact that he talked
to people to people here's Taylor saying
well you know Trump cares more about
investigating Biden than Ukraine how
does he draw that conclusion while he's
talked to people and those people have
talked to people and those people in
turn have talked to other people who
once talked to somebody who knew Trump
so your staff member here's the
president asking about the
investigations meaning verismo and the
Biden's in 2016 and ambassador sunland
told President Trump that the Ukrainians
were ready to move forward he did and I
think you said that after the call when
your staff asked best result and what
President Trump thought of Ukraine his
response was that President Trump cares
more about the investigations of Biden
is that right
and Marissa yes sir okay so here's
Taylor talking about what sunland
allegedly said to him as I've said all
along someone's testimony is gonna
matter I'm not sure that Bill Taylor's
testimony matters a whole hell of a lot
the person in the crosshairs now is
sunland and then Taylor said well I came
to believe that because someone told me
that okay fine
well again you're a third party hey then
Taylor says that Giuliani wanted to get
Biden there was his perception that
Giuliani was after Biden he wasn't after
investigating supposed corruption in
2016 or CrowdStrike he wasn't after
looking into the situation in Ukraine
during 2016 and whether they were
interfering in the election no bill
Taylor says knows Giuliani whose Trump's
personal lawyer who wanted to get by
you Juliana promoting US national
interests our policy in Ukraine
ambassador I don't think so ma'am mr.
Kent
no he was not what interests do you
believe he was promoting mr. Kent I
believe he was looking to dig up
political dirt against a potential rival
in the next election cycle ambassador
Taylor what interest do you believe he
was promoting I agree with mr. Kent
okay so again that is their perception
and that does not really make much of a
difference I'm sure the Democrats
believe the same thing I'm sure there
are some people who again it's plausible
who believe that Giuliani's sole task
and Ukraine was did he kept her on Biden
but that would not really explain why he
was so concerned with for example the
CrowdStrike server which was an evidence
less conspiracy theory nor does it
really explain why he was concerned
about Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election because that has nothing to do
with Biden right so here's the question
why was Giuliani spending time
investigating those other things if it
was all really about the Biden's okay
then there was George Kent so George
Kenseth this Undersecretary of state
he's the man who who you will see if you
subscribe to the show who you will see
sitting next to Bill Taylor he doesn't
get the same sort of enormous media
plaudits the tailor does right because
he wears a bowtie
which means that he doesn't have as much
gravitas because bowties don't have as
much gravitas as reassuring gray hair
obviously well Kent he basically
suggested many of the same things that
that tailor did but he made some claims
that were also a little bit outlandish I
mean his testimony was a little bit more
colorful actually which is I think why
the media is not covering it so much he
said a couple of things that cut in
favor of President trumpet he said a
couple of things that cut against
president from the first thing that he
said is he was asked about conditions
being placed on Ukrainian aid and he
said yeah conditions have always been
placed on Ukrainian aid which again is
true and cuts in favor of the idea that
the president has plenary power over
placing conditions on Ukrainian aid so
long as it is not a specific design to
go after a domestic political opponent
here as George Kent there are and always
have been conditionality placed on our
sovereign loan guarantees for Ukraine
conditions include anti-corruption
reforms as well as meeting larger
stability goals and social safety nets
the International Monetary Fund does the
same thing Congress in
the executive branch worked together to
put conditionality on some security
assistance in the Ukraine security
assistance initiative okay and that's
true right it is true Joe Biden put
obvious conditions on the ability of
Ukraine's receive loan guarantees for
example the question here is whether it
was legit or not so when people say well
Trump was withholding the aid therefore
something bad happened well no it
depends on the purpose for which you
which he was withholding the aid now I
said yesterday now I've been saying for
weeks that this requires us to discern
president Trump's intent was this about
2016 Ukrainian corruption was this about
his anger that the media have decided
that he won because of Russian
interference and so he was concerned
about Ukrainian interference in the
election was it him going off on some
tangential conspiracy theory about 2016
or was it specifically about Biden if it
was specifically about Biden in 2020
that's impeachable there's any of the
others it is not and I said yesterday I
don't think that Trump had the requisite
intent to go after Joe Biden because
that does not sound like Trump now I
exaggerated a little bit I said well I
don't think Trump has the intent to eat
a hamburger obviously I am joking when I
say that but I think that the problem
for Trump is that it is difficult to
discern what the man's intent is because
he doesn't tend to have large-scale
focused intent over long periods of time
he doesn't tend to have plans he tends
to have as I said yesterday on the show
a sort of flat vomit when it comes to a
lot of these issues and this is the
problem that Democrats have you paint
him as an idiot for years right you say
that he's a for years you say that
he doesn't have the capacity to put
together plans for years and now you
have swiveled and you are saying that he
has this very specific plan to get Joe
Biden and not only does he have this
plan to get Joe Biden and he has
deployed Giuliani he has told Giuliani
to cover his tracks by asking about
CrowdStrike and Ukrainian interference
in the 2016 election and he has also
told Sunland that he wants
investigations into ancillary matters
not involved with Biden just to cover
his tracks that does that sound like
Trump does that sound like Trump
okay well even George Kent's testimony
seems to suggest more that Rudy Giuliani
was mucking things up than that Trump
had specific intent to get Joe Biden
even though he believes that Trump had
specific intent to get Joe Biden here is
George Ken suggesting that was really
Giuliani's interference that was
screwing with the president's head over
the course of 2018 and 2019 I became
increasingly aware of an effort by Rudy
Giuliani and others including his
associates Lev / NAS and Igor Froome and
to run a campaign to smear ambassador
Jovanovic and other
officials at the US Embassy in Keefe the
chief agitators on the Ukrainian side of
this effort were some of those same
corrupt former prosecutors I had
encountered particularly yuriy lutsenko
and viktor Shokan they are now peddling
false information in order to extract
revenge against those who had exposed
their misconduct okay so if that is the
case they were peddling false
information and that that was being
peddled to Giuliani who was peddling it
to trump is that specific intent to get
Joe Biden really because that that again
that the whole thing comes down to
Trump's intent did he intend to get Joe
Biden or is that part of his bigger ball
of random thoughts about Ukraine and his
general antipathy toward Ukraine Karen
gets you more of George Kent's testimony
and then we'll get to the other issues
plus the performance of the various
players in this drama we'll get to all
of that in just one second first let's
talk about keeping your home safe so as
you may know I am now obsessive about
safety we just get all sorts of death
threats unfortunately I personally have
been made the subject of many death
threats just in the past couple of weeks
alone it's just a party all the time
it's a party well that means that I am
obsessed with security and that's one of
the reasons I have ring comm ring helps
you stay connected to your home from
anywhere if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you get an alert
you're able to see here speak to them
all from your phone if you're on the go
this season whether it's across town or
across the country you can check in
anytime for some much-needed holiday
peace of mind so I know exactly what is
going on on my property whether or not
I'm actually at my property which is
fantastic as a listener you have a
special holiday offer on a ring welcome
kit available right now with a ring
video doorbell - and a chime Pro the
ring welcome kit has everything you need
to keep an eye on home no matter what
this holiday season brings you don't
have to be a high-profile public figure
to worry about your safety at your house
and you should be worried about your
safety of your house if you're a
responsible human being and you have
kids for example or I just don't want
people messing around your property with
ring you're always home just go to ring
calm /pun that is ring that calm slash
been additional terms that may apply go
check them out right now it's company I
trust with my family safety which is my
number one issue ring calm /ban go check
them out right now ok so back to George
Kent and his testimony so then George
Kent gets into the vagaries of the sort
of theories Trump and Giuliani were
pursuing he says a couple of things one
of them is true and one of them not so
much so here's the one that the thing
that he says that is true he says there
is no factual basis to the CrowdStrike
theory now remember if you go back to
that
June 25th phone call between President
Trump and Vladimir zalenski the
president of Ukraine what you see is
that Trump is demanding a few things or
requesting a few things requesting is
probably more accurate from the
transcript of the or the memo that sort
of summarizes the transcript of the
phone call so the he requests a few
things one he wants an investigation
into Ukrainian corruption surrounding
the 2016 election two he wants an
investigation into CrowdStrike
because he has this weird theory that
Hillary Clinton's server was actually
not handed over to the FBI because it
had been hacked by the Ukrainians not by
the Russians and that CrowdStrike the
firm that did the actual analysis is
owned by Ukrainian and therefore Hillary
Clinton's actual server is buried
somewhere in a forest outside of Kiev
okay there's not a lot of evidence to
that particular theory and then there
was his talk about Purisima and the
Biden so there are a few issues that got
mentioned with regard to corruption in
Ukraine and Trump's request for
investigations so here's George Kent
correctly pointing out there is no
factual basis to the CrowdStrike theory
this of course is true but it does not
go to whether Trump's bolete and Trump
believes that was to remember let's say
for example let's say for asset for sake
of argument that the CrowdStrike theory
were true would it be in America's
interest to know whether in fact the
Ukrainians hacked Hillary Clinton's hard
drive and the DNC hard drive would that
be in America's interest to know yes it
certainly would well just because Trump
believed a bat bleep loony theory does
not mean that he was out to get Joe
Biden in fact it tends to support the
idea that he was out to protect
America's interests as he wrongly
perceived them with regard to
CrowdStrike so here as George Kent
knocking down the crowd strike theory
when he talks about this crowd strike
and the server what do you understand to
this to be a reference to to be honest I
had not heard of CrowdStrike until I
read this transcript on September 25th
do you now understand what it relates to
I understand it has to do with the story
that there's a server with missing
emails I also understand that one of the
owners of or of CrowdStrike is a Russian
American I'm not aware of any Ukrainian
connection to the company okay
and then Ken says something so all of
that is true and then Kent is asked
about Ukrainian interference in the 2016
election now here he's got a problem
because the fact is that Politico
reported as it other outlets that there
was a nexus between the
crane Ian's Embassy in the Hillary
Clinton campaign and then a woman in
alexandra chalupa had been visiting the
Ukrainian embassy trying to dig up dirt
on home Anna Ford okay those are public
reports from Politico here's George Kent
saying there's no factual basis to claim
that Ukraine interfered in the 2016
election they may be true with regard to
Ukraine and hacking into servers but it
is certainly not true with regard to
their coordination with the DNC and
Hillary Clinton now are you aware that
this is all part of a larger allegation
that Ukraine interfered in the 2016
election yes that is my understanding
and to your knowledge is there any
factual basis to support the allegation
that Ukraine interfered in the 2016
election to my knowledge there's no
factual basis no okay well okay how
about some political knowledge how about
some mainstream media reports because
there are those reports out there so
unless he is firmly rebutting the
political report I'm not sure what he is
talking about okay so there you have the
testimony that is the summary of the
testimony Taylor and Kent basically
saying that they they think very
strongly they have opinions and those
opinions are very strong opinions and
those very strong opinions mean that
Trump did a very very bad thing the only
thing that we got knew from either of
the testimonies here is Bill Taylor
suggesting that he had an aide who
overheard Gordon sunland talking to
Trump and talking about investigations
and how the Ukrainians were going to
accede to Trump's requests so he should
release the aide right that is the only
thing that is new that puts pressure on
Gordon sunland but again I'm wondering
why it is that Bill Taylor is testifying
as to what his aide heard from Sunland
as opposed to you know the aide coming
forward and testifying as to what he
heard from someone because now we are
not talking about even a secondhand
report of what Trump said we don't even
know what Trump said on the other end of
the line all we know is that apparently
Cornville Taylor Trump talked to Sunland
Sunland was at some sort of public
restaurant one of Taylor's aides was at
the same restaurant and overheard
Sunland side of the conversation
and then the aide went and talked to
Bill Taylor so bill Taylor is now three
degrees removed from President Trump I
am more closely related to Kevin Bacon
than that you know again that doesn't
mean that the accounts of the
conversation is false it just means that
it doesn't say anything about what Trump
was even saying on the other side of the
conversation and this is a point you're
gonna hear Republicans hammer home in
just one moment because this really was
the Republican counter-attack was you're
bringing forth these star witnesses and
none of them have had ever had a
conversation with Trump that are removed
from the actual
policymaking apparatus and that by the
way is their complaint right their
complaint is we were removed from the
policy-making apparatus we were not part
of these conversations so if you can't
have it both ways either you're mad that
you were not part of the conversations
and therefore you are not privy to the
information that people who were part of
the conversations are privy to or you
weren't part of the conversation but you
don't have enough evidence to get Trump
so one of those two things is true and
both of them establish that you are not
in fact star witnesses that you are in
fact just the best that Democrats can
offer right now because the fact is that
if you actually wanted to break down
what was going on in Trump's mind you
need to talk to one of three or four
people Rudy Giuliani Gordon Sunland who
will be called you need to talk to Mick
Mulvaney maybe John Bolton that's about
it I'm not aware that anybody else was
privy to the mind of President Trump and
yet Democrats are trying in the media
are trending up Bill Taylor who again
has never spoken to Trump and George
Kent who has never spoken to Trump
you're gonna hear Republicans hammering
home this point and it is a very telling
point we're gonna get to that in just
one second first it's about the time of
year for open enrollment and that means
that you are checking out you are
looking right now at your life insurance
policies well good for you you should
but if you think that that life
insurance that you got right now from
your employer is actually going to cover
your needs probably not the fact is that
most people need about ten times the
life insurance coverage they get through
their jobs and that means that your
employer life insurance is leaving you
underinsured that's where policy genius
can help policy genius is the easy way
to shop for a life insurance plan that
is not tied to your job in minutes you
can compare quotes from top insurers and
find your best price once you apply the
policy genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape the life
insurance you buy through policy genius
also stays with you it's not attached to
your employer so if God forbid you lose
your job you still have that life
insurance policy so when you're looking
at your workplace benefits this month
make sure to double-check those life
insurance options by the way if you have
other insurance needs you should also
check out policy genius because they do
home insurance and auto insurance and
disability insurance to one-stop shop
for insurance basically head on over to
policy genius.com to get quotes and
apply in a minute insure yourself that's
what responsible human beings do policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance check them out at policy
genius.com to get those quotes and apply
in minutes already we're gonna get to
more of this because there's plenty more
to get to more analysis the Republican
fight back the Democrats kind of blowing
it we'll get to that in a second if
you're not already a subscriber
however you are really missing out
need to subscribe head on over to daily
wire.com slash subscribe for as little
as ten bucks a month you got all of our
articles had free access to all of our
live broadcasts our full show library
select bonus content our exclusive daily
wire app which is in fact a pretty great
feature if you haven't checked it out
yet if you choose the new All Access
plan you get all of that plus the
legendary leftist cheers tumbler and our
brand-new asked me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage our hosts writers and special
guests on a weekly basis by the way how
popular is this leftist chair stumble
right here this magnificent piece of s
aware how great is it it's so great that
Elizabeth Warren is now copying it she
put out a mug that says on a
billionaires tears there's only one
problem with that the sales of those mug
are powered by Spotify I believe it's
yeah it's it's Spotify right so and
Spotify happens to be owned by a
billionaire so billionaire tears bicep
buy a mug to catch Elizabeth Warren's
billionaire tears in order that the
money can go to a billion or a pretty
great cell phone there from from
Elizabeth Warren so Shopify Shopify's is
the owner it pretty spectacular stuff in
any case if you want the original the
greatest and the most accurate go check
out daily wire right now and get the
subscription and get the leftist tears
tumbler stop depriving yourself come
join the fun we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so here is the problem right
all of these witnesses I say Taylor Kent
these are people who are not firsthand
witnesses to events that actually matter
right there are secondhand witnesses to
all of the actual information that is
flowing there they are third hand fourth
hand witnesses in some cases and this is
how you end up with the bizarre
spectacle of one of the Democrats on the
House Intelligence Committee
it was Quigley suggesting that hearsay
can be better evidence than direct
evidence which is just know it no that's
that's incorrect sir here is
representative Quigley I think the
American public needs reminded that
countless people have been convicted on
hearsay because the courts have
routinely allowed and created needed
exceptions to hearsay hearsay it can be
much better evidence than direct as we
have learned in painful instances and
it's certainly valid in and this sense
mmm
nope no that's Mike Quigley from
Illinois being a horrible lawyer
apparently no that that is not right
here's a is generally not better than
direct evidence and when he talks about
the exceptions to hearsay exceptions to
the hearsay rule generally include
things like party admissions and
statements against interest but it
actually has to include you know like
the party themself not like a third
party saying something or a dying
declaration which again comes directly
from the party or past recollection
record right these are some of the
exceptions and none of those apply here
when we're talking hearsay we're not
just talking about like somebody said
that Trump said they're talking about
somebody said that an aide said that
someone said that Trump said no that is
not better than direct evidence it
certainly certainly is not Republicans
hone in on this point right so
Republicans are going to hammer down on
on all of this Elise Stefanik well
actually let's start with with Mike
Turner's representative Mike Turner from
I believe Ohio he says listen you you
keep talking about Trump's thought
processes you've never actually met the
President or had contact with the
president have you ambassador Taylor is
that you testified in your prior
testimony that you have not had any
contact with the president I'd states
that correct that's correct sir
Miss Taylor mr. Kent have you had any
contact with President States I have not
so not only no conversations with the
president I'd say it's about Ukraine
you've not had any contact with the
president
States correct that's correct okay so
you both know that this impeachment
inquiry is about the president ID States
don't you I mean the man that neither
one of you have had any contact with
you're the first up witnesses I just
find that a little amazing that that
that the first up would be two people
who've never had any contact with the
President himself um yes this would be
the operative point right and this is
the this is the reason why I've been
saying all along that if the Democrats
actually wish to get Trump they need to
bring in people who spoke directly to
Trump or Trump himself right those are
the only options here instead they bring
in Bill Taylor and George Kent who've
never met the President and never spoken
to the president Jim Jordan the
representative from Ohio he made the
exact same point he said you guys are
the star witnesses right there huh the
Democrats are highlighting you is the
star witnesses you don't even know the
person that you're testifying about
here's Jim Jordan going after the same
point so you weren't on the call were
you the president you didn't listen on
president Trump's call and present less
he's call either Dodd you've never
talked with chief of staff Mulvaney
I've never did you never met the
president that's correct he had three
meetings again with szalinski and didn't
come up and two of those they had never
heard about as far as I know president
there's no reason for presidents Leske
never made an announcement this is this
is what I can't believe and you're their
star witness you're their first witness
you're the guy based on this based on I
mean I've seen I've seen church prayer
chains that are easier to understand
than this and that is absolutely true I
mean you can even see with a even Bill
Taylor looks a little bit like flustered
by this because of course it's true I
mean listen I know that his gray hair is
reassuring but it is also true that the
guy has no actual inside information
he's not privy to the thought process
that would make this bribery as opposed
to just a normal exercise of
foreign-policy power in a way that the
foreign policy foreign policy
establishment doesn't like or even even
if it's an abnormal exercise and foreign
policy power that doesn't make an
illegitimate as an impeachable form of
foreign policy power exercise even if
you think that it's bad that doesn't
make it impeachable and i tend to think
that this is bad policy based on bad
information funneled by Rudy Giuliani it
does make an impeachable and trying to
bring out witnesses who have no actual
window into Trump state of mind is
definitely a bizarre move Jordan really
hammered this point home even more he
says
let me just read you sort of the the
chain of events here and you tried to
explain it to me let me read one more
time ambassador Taylor recalls that mr.
Morrison told ambassador Taylor that I
told Mr Morrison that I conveyed this
message to mr. Sharma on September 1st
2019 in connection with vice president
pence his visit to Warsaw and a meeting
with President Olinsky we've got six
people having four conversations in one
sentence and you just told me this is
where you got your clear understanding
that is that again I think this is what
the American people are going to take
away Jordan doing an excellent job of
pointing this out or as Democrats
Democrats would claim obfuscating the
issue but I think that that's actually a
fair point which is that these people
are in a chain of communication that
isn't the actual chain of communication
that matters and they acknowledge as
such here's the thing
both Taylor and Kent basically
acknowledge they were outside the actual
chain the the unofficial chain of
information upon which was met upon
which Trump was making his decisions now
where Republicans are on a little bit
weaker ground is when they tried to
argue that if the Democrats prove their
Hayes it still would not be impeachable
so you have Elise Stefanik who is an
excellent young congresswoman from New
York and she says you know there are a
couple of key facts Democrats are
ignoring here and those key facts make
it so that this is utterly unimpeachable
conduct I think this is an overstatement
by Elise Stefanik
for the millions of Americans viewing
today the two most important facts are
the following number one Ukraine
received the eighth number two there was
in fact no investigation into Biden okay
well that is not enough right obviously
the accusation is that Trump was
withholding the aid in order to achieve
a particular foreign policy purpose when
that came to light then he tried to
backfill the problem right that's that's
not enough and you're hearing
Republicans repeat that point so
Republicans are deploying a few defenses
one is an obvious lawyer defense which
makes a lot of sense
you don't know Trump's intent you don't
know his state of mind you don't know of
his motives and trying to establish
those motives through the testimony of
somebody who once heard of Trump who
once ate at the same restaurant of Trump
is not going to is not going to do it
and then you have the the Republicans
stronger defense this is the one Trump
wants them to push which is he never did
anything wrong and that one I think is a
lot harder to push and John Ratcliffe
tried to do the same thing he said to
the Democrats you know call out the
impeachable offense like we're gonna
need to hear the impeachable offense
here hearing today where we impeach
presidents for tree
or bribery or other high crimes where is
the impeachable offense in that call are
either of you here today to assert there
was an impeachable offense in that call
shouted out anyone ok but he is not just
in that call right I mean that is also a
bit of a misnomer just trying to analyze
this fairly nobody is claiming that the
call itself is the impeachable offense
they are claiming that the policy linked
to the call for several months here was
the impeachable was the impeachable
claim again all that Trump has to do
like any good defense case he doesn't
have to prove that he is quote unquote
innocent of any bad activity he just has
to show that he didn't do anything
criminal and the criminal activity at
issue here is bribery which includes an
intent right includes an intent it is
amazing the Democrats will read intent
out of the law when it is convenient to
them and they will read intent into the
law when it is convenient to them so
Hillary Clinton takes classified
information puts it on her own personal
home brew server in her bathroom and Jim
Comey will say no no that's not
prosecutable because she didn't have a
intent to expose that information to
prying eyes sure she had intent to
misuse classified information but she
didn't have intent to expose that
information to the Russians or to
anybody else to prying eyes and he read
an intent element that is not in the law
into the law and I said that based on
precedent yeah I think that that is a
bad practice I think it's arguable at
best okay and then Democrats will say
okay well yes bribery requires intent
but we don't have to prove intent we can
just assume intent well no you can't if
you actually want to prove intent you
have to prove intent well President
Trump reacted to all of the hearings
yesterday he got a bit personal with
Adam Schiff of course he said that Adam
Schiff had to bring in a ringer because
he's not capable of doing his own
questioning which of course is sort of
for Republicans by the way also brought
in a ringer so it's not not a perfectly
fair statement but here is from going
after chef I'm too busy to watch it it's
a witch hunt it's a hoax I'm too busy to
watch it so I'm sure I'll get a report
there's nothing there's I have not been
briefed no there's nothing there I see
they're using lawyers that are
television lawyers they took some guys
off television you know I'm not
surprised to see it because Schiff can't
do his own questions it's Trump just
taking a chiffon chef it's a pretty
solid stuff right there from from
President
but you would come to expect now the
only headline that may come out of this
is that remember the only thing that's
new in any of this testimony is Taylor
testifying again
and one of his aides overheard Gordon
sunland the ambassador to the EU talking
to Trump about investigations Trump is
asked about this and he says he doesn't
remember any of the he doesn't remember
any phone call referenced by Taylor here
I know nothing about that first time
I've heard it
the one thing I've seen that soundin
said was that he did speak to me for a
brief moment and I said no quid pro quo
under any circumstances and that's true
than the other I've never heard this in
any event it's more secondhand
information but I've never heard it no
not even a little bit the only thing and
I guess Saarland had stayed with his
testimony that there was no quid pro quo
okay so Trump is saying the only
conversation I had with someone is one
in which I explicitly told him that
there was not a quid pro quo someone of
course says he believes that there was
in fact a quid pro quo
this could get Trump in trouble if
someone were to get up and say no no
actually there was a phone call and
Taylor was right and we did talk about
in the investigations you know
presumably Trump could just I didn't
remember that conversation right
--chrome could also theoretically say it
was the same conversation as the one
where I said no quid pro quo because you
didn't hear my side of the conversation
but that is the only new news from this
entire day is that Taylor claimed there
was another call Trump says he doesn't
remember another call so we'll find out
the truth about that because someone's
gonna testify okay so is any of this
devastating or bombshell is anything
that we've said so far a devastating
bombshell tossed into the middle of
impeachment or is it basically just
Democrats putting on a TV show for
people and it's obvious which this is
because you can see how the media are
analyzing it the New York Times for
example called in their television
critic to actually do an analysis of how
this thing looked on TV so we all know
what this is it's it's it's made for TV
drama James Poniewozik who is their TV
critic wrote a piece for the New York
Times called a tale of an irregular
Channel playing on many channels in the
middle of the testimony of William B
Taylor jr. the top American diplomat in
Ukraine that opened the house
impeachment hearings Wednesday a
guessing game broke out on social media
he sounded like someone didn't he his
deep assuring steady voice reminded some
people of Tom Brokaw no maybe it was
Walter Cronkite
ruk can't Cronkite's and word r murrow
it's telling that all these comparisons
were to old school news anchors because
i think what people were hearing and mr.
taylor's gravelly composure was the
voice not so much of another person but
another time a time of authoritative
voices that a wide audience found
credible it was like a science fiction
story in which someone turns on an old
radio and here's a staticky broadcast
from the past even the text of mr.
Taylor's introduction had a Cronkite Ian
ring I am NOT here to take one side or
the other he said my sole purpose is to
provide facts as I know them and that's
the way it is but this was in fact at
2019 where there is no unified audience
willing to accept a single way that
anything is and then he just goes on to
talk about the optics of this whole
thing because it's just like Walter
Cronkite and so again the media are
reviewing this thing from a television
perspective there's a whole column in
The Washington Post by Robin and given
their fashion critic suggesting that Jim
Jordan needs to put on a jacket
obviously the most important element of
our times is weather is weather Jim
Jordan is wearing a jacket or not by the
way Jim Jordan never wears a jacket I
mean if ever ever been in any of the
hearings and I mean I've testified in
front of Jim Jordan in Congress he does
not wear a jacket this is not like
something new but she says of course
representative Jim Jordan took his seat
Wednesday morning at the opening of the
public impeachment hearings on Capitol
Hill wearing nothing but a shirt sleeves
no suit jacket that's how Jordan dresses
it's his power move his sartorial chest
thump all the other members of the House
Intelligence Committee turned up in
suits and ties or other businesses hire
but not Jordan everyone else was willing
to offer at least a symbolic nod to
chorus formality it's that old-fashioned
notion of civility Jordan announced
himself as the man who was itching to
rumble he was the guy who came not to do
as the Constitution demands with
measured deliberation not to brawl she
could tell all this by the fact he
wasn't wearing a suit jacket which he
never wears I've met Jim Jordan several
times he has never worn a suit jacket as
far as I'm aware I don't even know that
he owns a suit jacket the man probably
buys his suit jacket and his pants
separately at Macy's like I don't know
he doesn't do that but apparently
according to Washington but that's the
big takeaway the big takeaway from all
of this bombshell Jim Jordan doesn't
wear jackets Jordan has a reputation for
rarely wearing a suit jacket
The Washington Post acknowledges but
Twitter accounts is dedicated to his
jacket lessness he's the man on
who refuses to show witnesses the same
respect they never inevitably show to
him ants the circumstances typically men
who are called to testify before
Congress wear a suit they recognized the
seriousness of the situation and they
dignify it even Mark Zuckerberg will
know single-handedly made hoodies and
t-shirts the uniform of the modern mogul
wears the suit when comedian Hasan
Minhaj went to Capitol Hill to discuss
student loan debt he also wore a suit
the extras in the audience as the
impeachment drama unfolds were wearing
suit jackets the witnesses were in suit
jackets but Jordan in his role as
representative of the American people
couldn't be bothered to suit up when
Jordan was interviewed recently by Wall
Street Journal reporter about why he
doesn't wear a jacket he said quote I'm
not even sure I don't know why but of
course that was disingenuous after a
pause he admitted he does wear a jacket
when the rules require him to do so as
when he's on the House floor and he
wears a jacket when he aims to be
respectful such as when he is in the
company of the president on a visit to
the White House
presumably he doesn't consider sitting
alongside his colleagues during a matter
of national importance to be a situation
that deserves his high regard I remember
that time when Barack Obama didn't wear
Jack in the Oval Office and some people
were like oh that's that's terrible that
he didn't do that
Ronald Reagan always used to put on a
jacket me know like how dare you say
that about Barack Obama how dare you now
it's Jim Jordan doesn't wear a jacket
it's the end of the world by the way I
just should point out that despite the
fact there was no devastating bombshell
testimony yesterday listen to CBS talk
about the devastating bombshell
testimony yesterday and there we have it
day one of the first public hearings in
terms of each 'men inquiry against the
president Donald Trump are now in the
history books some devastating testimony
today from two of America's most
respected diplomats who have served both
Republican and Democratic presidents so
bombshell so testimony yeah except that
nothing new happened and that's the real
story of yesterday okay time for a thing
I like and then a quick thing that I
hate so things that I like today so I
was watching old movies while I was on
my trip to Boston and I watched I was he
was streaming on Prime Saturday Night
Fever which I'd never seen it's sort of
a classic movie from the 1970s with a
very very young John Travolta the movie
is actually quite good it's been
parodied so much in movies like airplane
do you forget that the movie is actually
pretty good it also is a relic of a time
and when you watch it you realize that
that time then
1970s as scuzzy and terrible as it was
in a wide variety of ways that our
sensitivities now would not allow a
movie like this to be made it wouldn't I
mean John Travolta his character
spoiler alert from a movie that is that
is nearly 50 years old at this point but
spoiler alert John Travolta at one point
attempts to nearly rape a female
character in the movie and she ends up
being friends with him at the end of the
movie that would certainly not be
allowed in a movie today it's a very
gritty movie and people forget how
gritty the movie is because it's about
disco but here is a little bit of the
preview for Saturday Night Fever very
iconic stuff John Travolta walking down
the street and the playing of the Bee
Gees and all of this sort of stuff but
the movie is a pretty good examination
of sort of Brooklyn life circa 1977 and
it's a it's a good reminder that
cultural sub that the sort of cultural
breakdown can happen in virtually any
community right there's really a movie
about cultural breakdown about the evils
of the sexual revolution actually quite
a conservative when you come right down
to it so if you if you if you don't
remember that it's worth checking out
again movie Saturday Night Fever plus
the dancing is actually pretty good
right John Travolta actually hit dance
back in the day all right time for a
quick thing that I hate okay so quick
things that I hate well first of all I
just it's sort of a thing that I like is
I showed up at Boston University last
night is great 1,500 students came out
packed house is in the Boston Athletic
Arena which was pretty cool it was kind
of a neat setting and it was a lot of
fun a lot of protesters showed up
outside which is I mean more power to
them I said last night like if you show
up in 20-degree weather it actually
protests more power to you because I've
been that so many schools where it is
cold and protesters say they're gonna
show up and then they check it out so at
least in Boston they have the power of
their convictions that they were
protesting me suggesting that I was a
racist because the name of the speech
was America wasn't built on slavery it
was built on freedom they were
suggesting I was gonna make light of
slavery I then spent 45 minutes
explaining the role of slavery in
America's history it's great evil and
the transition away from slavery and
America's defeat of slavery and defeat
of Jim Crow segregation and so it didn't
go quite how the left thought it was
gonna go because the left has this weird
picture of conservatives as people who
deny American history which of course is
not true it is the left that frequently
denies American
in favor of a darker version of American
history that simply isn't true there
they're a bunch of protesters four of
all sides there are some people who
showed up from sort of the the
nationalist conservative side of the
aisle there were a few all writers who
showed up as well there were some people
who there's a transgender protester
there it was a bit of fun but this is
sort of this is how things should go on
campus right it was an open conversation
everybody had a good time but that is
not what is happening on our college
campuses now it is very very very bad
obviously if you allow this sort of
thing to go on the University of Florida
has a student body president and this
flew the student body president is now
apparently facing impeachment for
allowing Donald from junior to speak on
campus his book is number one on the New
York Times bestseller list he's
obviously a public figure all sorts of
public figures get to speak on college
campuses particularly public college
campuses like the University of Florida
now the student body president is facing
impeachment according to the New York
Times a sitting president is facing
impeachment accused of collusion and
abusing his power support falls along
political lines the opposition party is
determined to remove him his allies
maintain he did nothing wrong but this
impeachment inquiry is taking place far
from Washington even though the football
stadium known as the swamp looms nearby
student representatives at the
University of Florida introduced a bill
on Tuesday to impeach of Michael Murphy
the student body president accusing him
of improperly using student fees to pay
one of presidents from sons to speak on
campus it all began when mr. Murphy a
senior invited Donald Trump jr. in
kimberly guilfoyle a former Fox News
host and advisor to the president's
campaign to speak on campus and paid
them 50 grand with university funds some
students say the payment was a violation
of the Student Senate code and possibly
the law the backlash intensified after
the campus newspaper the independent
Florida alligator published emails
showing that Murphy had spoken with a
consultant for Trump's re-election
campaign to set up the visit and that
mr. Murphy had attended Trump's
inauguration
okay does any of that mean it's
illegitimate to invite a public figure
like Donald Trump jr. near campus not
that I am aware of by the way how many
payments have been made to left-wing
speakers at University of Florida I
would suggest more than a few students
who drafted the impeachment bill
personally handed Murphy a copy of it on
Tuesday night they argue in the bill
that Murphy's use of student funds
violates the Student Senate code which
forbids spending student fees to support
a political party they accept the Donald
Trump jr. isn't running for office
so this has led to this sour split on
campus Jared Rodriguez is a junior and
treasurer for the University of Florida
College Republicans he said that this
move is quote a mirror image for the
partisan politics at the national level
he said he attended the talk and never
viewed as a campaign event the drive to
oust mr. Murphy he said showed that the
opposition party would look for anything
to remove the elected president he said
I think they have no cigar in both cases
but again the idea here is that if you
that the real problem of course is that
they don't want Trump jr. speaking on
campus or I mean that's that's really
what this is about just like all these
Boston University students in want me
speaking on campus they don't want
conservatives speaking on campus doesn't
matter if it's Trump does matter if it's
me
nobody they don't want anybody there it
doesn't matter what the people say by
the way like at all
again I spoke at Stanford last week and
protests are shouted for me to leave
while I was ripping into Nazis I mean
it's unbelievable so this is just the
latest iteration of campus radicalism it
is stupid it is ridiculous and it is it
is contrary to the goal of the
University in the first place thank you
by the way of Boston University for
making sure that the event could happen
in safety and security the
administration did a fine job over there
all righty we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content Plus check us out
tonight over at daily wire comm the
reason you should well if you subscribe
then you get full access to our daily
wire backstage which will be discussing
impeachment and many other issues of the
day it should be a lot of fun and if you
are a subscriber then you get to ask the
questions and you get all the goodies
behind the paywall so go do that right
now otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Joshua all Vera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation